[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain the japanese film called the
taste of tea
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie revolves around the haruno
family who lives in a small village in
japan at the beginning of the movie the
grandfather plays with the youngest
daughter sachiko haruno as the little
girl sits alone behind her we see her
doppelganger double the size of her
sachiko has been troubled by this
massive version of herself following her
around she thinks of ways to get rid of
it often but is never actually tried
anything
one day at school she is in the morning
assembly yawning because she is bored at
the same time she sees her larger self
sitting on the bars and yawning as well
in the classroom sachiko dives into her
thoughts and thinks of ways to get rid
of the giant she remembers a story her
uncle ayano had told her and her brother
a few years back when ayano was just a
boy there used to be a large forest
called the haunted forest people used to
say that the forest was cursed and
anyone who went there attracted spirits
one day ayano was roaming around the
jungle collecting bird's eggs but he had
forgotten to go to the toilet before
leaving so he was struggling to hold it
in he tells himself that he can make it
home in time but changes his mind when
he sees a large egg on the ground he
decides to defecate on the egg after
that as he pulls his pants up he notices
that the egg is half underground he
starts thinking about why someone buried
such a massive egg instead of bringing
it home with them then he sees the feces
on top of the egg and thinks that
defecating on it might be weirder than
burying it thinking about a lot of
things he leaves the jungle for the day
since the thought of the egg never
leaves his mind ayano goes back on
another day to look for it but since he
is not familiar with the jungle he never
finds the egg again
however ayano doesn't give up and looks
for the egg every day until one day a
man with several tattoos and blood
dripping from his body appears in front
of him ayano looks at him in fear but
the man says nothing from that day
onwards he sees the man everywhere at
first ayano is terrified and bothered by
the stranger following him but with time
he gets used to being followed he also
mentions that the stranger had feces on
his head one day when iano was able to
do a flip on the playground bar the man
disappeared and never came back again
sachiko also contemplates learning to do
a backflip to get rid of her giant but
what she doesn't know is that the day
the man stopped following ayano the
police had found a skull buried in the
forest with feces on top of it so it
turns out the egg ayano defecated on was
actually a human skull
in the following scene we see sachiko's
elder brother hajime in his school he
has a love letter in his hands addressed
to him by some girl she calls him to
meet in a restaurant after school
later we see four of hajime's friends in
this restaurant talking about girls one
of them is dressed as a girl as well as
they talk we find out that the love
letter was actually left by them so they
can prank hajime just then hajime cycles
towards the restaurant and the boys get
ready to prank him however to their
disappointment he cycles to his home
without stopping by the restaurant a
voice narrates to us that hajime has
lost his faith in relationships after he
heard a couple fighting about cosmetic
surgeries in a restaurant and after he
saw a guy who was beaten by his
girlfriend
next we see hajime and sachiko's mother
yoshiko at her job she works as a
designer in animated film projects her
boss is a pervert who wants to get
together with yoshiko that day he scolds
a worker for bringing her pet to work
later at night everyone is at home when
the father nobuo plays a board game
called go with hajime the boy has been
playing the game for a long time and is
getting quite good at it the next day at
school a student named suzuishi is
transferred to hajime's class he
instantly develops feelings for the girl
but is too shy to even talk to her after
school we see grandfather akira ayano
sachiko and mother yoshiko drinking tea
together they stay in silence for a very
long time enjoying the beverage sometime
later sachiko runs to the living room
and stares into nothingness her giant
doppelganger is also beside her sitting
in silence
fed up with the giant she finally
decides to learn to do a backflip on a
bar and get rid of it she runs to a
restricted area nearby where lies a
deserted playground however she looks at
the playing bar for a long time and
returns back home without trying to play
on it the following day at school a girl
asks the new transfer student suzuishi
what club she will choose for after
school practice suzuishi says that she
wants to join the board game go
club hajime hears this and is over the
moon knowing that he and suzui shi share
an interest on his way back home he
cycles while fantasizing about suzuishi
later when he is alone in his room
hajime fantasizes an elaborate fake
scenario and fights imaginary men to
save his girl in the following scene he
is back in school that evening suzuishi
is with her friend talking as he spies
on her from afar after a while he meets
his father while returning home on a
metro they both witness two men in some
kind of costumes making noise and
clicking pictures when they get off the
metro the men get in a fight with some
strangers and the father and the son run
away from the scene now the family is at
the dinner table as the two tell of what
they saw in the metro ayano almost
doesn't believe them because of the
absurdity of the incident the next day
the mother of the family yoshiko is at
work before leaving she asks her boss
not to call her the following day
because she is on leave it is evident
that he has been bothering her to go out
with him he promises to leave her alone
but as soon as she leaves he calls her
husband and tells him yoshiko is
cheating on him yoshiko who is just
outside the door hears this and attacks
her boss for spreading rumors about her
cut to the next scene sachiko wakes up
to a nightmare of her and her
doppelganger swimming together she runs
to the abandoned playground again and
gets on the play bar for the first time
at the same time ayano goes to a shop
owned by his ex-girlfriend who is now
married to another man he talks to her
awkwardly at first but then opens up and
says he is glad she is happy in her life
the girl says the same and the two
separate after getting a closure of
their relationship after that he lays by
the side of a river to relax he notices
a man his age dancing nearby and
befriends him the next day yoshiko gets
a call from her boss who wants uncle
ayano's help since ianno is a manga
artist and a record producer he wants
him to record a song he even invites
grandfather akira to be in his music
video at first ayano declines to record
his song but he eventually agrees after
the family asks him to the grandfather
is very happy to be a part of the song
and begins singing day and night later
that day sachiko is in her classroom and
her giant companion is watching her
while lying on the school's playground
after school she goes to the playground
again to practice backflipping this time
her grandfather watches her from afar
and is relieved that she isn't doing
something harmful he leaves soon after
at night ayano brings his new friend
over for dinner after dinner the family
sits together as the father nobuo who
happens to be a hypnotherapist performs
a procedure on everyone to make them
relax he tries to hypnotize everyone but
it only works on yoshiko ayano and his
new friend the three fall unconscious
while sitting up
after a while they regain their
consciousness and say that they feel
rejuvenated the mother yoshiko explains
to her daughter how it feels to be
hypnotized since she didn't get to enjoy
the experience she describes it as being
able to move freely in space the next
day hajime goes to the library to return
some books on the board game go the
members of the go club notice his
interest and invite him to join the club
since they are low on members hajime
shyly accepts the offer and goes to the
club with them suzuishi is there too he
plays a game against a boy and easily
wins it as suzui she watches however she
leaves right after without talking to
him at the same time sachiko is at the
playground practicing doing a backflip
when a man's head emerges from the
ground sachiko runs away in fear and is
caught by two men she tells them about
the mud man the three return to the
playground and rescue the man who claims
he had been stuck underground for three
days at night she tells the story to her
mother and two of her co-workers who
have come over for dinner some days
later ayano records a song for akira and
yoshiko's boss after listening to the
awful song ayano and his co-workers are
shown flying to the sky
one day at school suzuishi is playing a
game of go with a friend but he leaves
midway as she packs up hajime enters the
room he sees she is alone and is about
to leave but suzuishi challenges him to
a game of go the two begin to play in
silence
all of a sudden hajime tells suzuishi
that it was his dream to play a match of
go with her suzuishi then tells him that
they should play every day after the
game they leave the school together
under the same umbrella hajime is over
the moon to finally be able to talk to
his crush the next day at work yoshiko
presents her animation to her co-workers
it is inspired by the feelings she goes
through when she is hypnotized everyone
loves the animation and claps for
yoshiko in appreciation
back at home sachiko peeps into her
grandfather's room to see him lying limp
on the floor in the following scene we
see the whole family in a metro
returning home after the grandfather's
funeral later the four of them sit at
the front porch and drink tea in silence
remembering their grandfather then they
go into his study room and look through
his belongings to their surprise they
find sketchbooks with paintings of the
whole family in the paintings yoshiko is
seen walking with an umbrella nobuo is
running hajime is on his bicycle while
sachiko is doing a backflip on a playing
bar in the following scene we see hajime
with suzuishi playing go while talking
to her confidently yoshiko is working on
her animations while sachiko is in the
playground attempting to do a backflip
she finally manages to do one and
freezes in shock just then her giant
self emerges from the ground and flies
away to the sky
a giant sunflower also emerges from the
same place and engulfs sachiko it grows
bigger and bigger ultimately taking over
the whole world and turning into dust at
last sachiko levitates back to the
playground the movie ends as we are
shown all the characters of the movie
watching the beautiful sunset
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a comment if
you have any idea what the hell this
movie was about thank you for watching